spider-man is going to be rebooted again
that's right we had Tobey Maguire one
then we had the Andrew Garfield one I
thought the second one just absolutely
sucked with the electro and green goblin
not good right can we just say not good
right oh my god not good not good did
you see it no I mean I don't know there
was a second I thought this was the 81
well there were the original three
technically they were the three Tobey
Maguire ones and then there was the to
hedrick attract any way they were owned
by sony Sony had the rights to them so
that's why spider-man hasn't been part
of the bigger Marvel world mostly the
Avengers and all that but now Sony and
Marvel are going to come together
they're going to reboot this thing it
sounds like spider-man is going to jump
in in a Captain America movie next year
then maybe something with the Avengers
etcetera etcetera but the reason I
thought this was an interesting story
because it goes to the superhero stuff
which everyone likes talking about but
then also how studios work and how big
money controls things spider-man is a
marvel character so back in the day in
the comic books they had crossovers with
no problems um so first let's just talk
about the superhero thing in general
which I we've talked about this a little
bit yeah um you think the superhero
movies have just completely gotten out
of control like it seems like it's the
only thing we can do in America I mean I
can't remember we talked about this last
time I was here actually but there was a
great piece the only times that talked
about the Irish potato famine and the
Irish native him happened because they
became a one crop economy and one when
that one crop dies you are yeah so I
think that Hollywood needs to watch it
because yes the-the-the superhero movies
on the up till now have been a wise
investment they're certainly they do
well globally you know people get
excited it's they they they generate
center the next movie which is the thing
that they love uh but you know beware
the one crop economy because when people
get sick of them they got any they have
to have something to fall back and and
real quick I mean not only are they they
huge money making things but you're
right about this sort of next thing cuz
now I think another time we had you on
Joe we laid out this chart right they
put together like swirl baby really laid
out the next five years and how they're
linking it's actually pretty cool how
they're starting to link movies together
and obviously DC is doing some of this
with Batman and Superman how do you feel
about the superhero movies in general
you know novice put that way I mean of
course there's tons of them and then I
think they need to stop naming them this
but this
Batman this Batman this spider-man this
that movie because it does kinda get
confusing to people who don't know the
logistics and the business side of how
everything keeps changing and that
because the links are actually cool
especially for comic I think comic book
fans i'm not one of yeah but it kind of
makes you want if you know the stories
can link to it also makes you have to
keep watch the next one could you
continuing story book yeah that was the
Marvel Universe strategy in the first
place was that if you really wanna know
is going on a fantastic for you to read
this issue the Avengers that issue of
you know iron fist or whatever because
they all linked in together yeah and you
would think that DC not having sold off
their characters the way marvel did back
in the day before these movies were so
viable it all being under the the the
time warner roof that they would have
been the pioneers here but no yeah they
absolutely did so finally they're
getting the batman superman thing but
and their Wonder Woman eighth wonder
over the Aquaman will be there there are
there belatedly getting on the train is
Aquaman actually happening oh yeah yeah
yeah no no it's a real thing with Jason
Momoa do it wow I did but yeah yeah
basically what happened i think the
weekend that the grosses for the first
Avengers came out heads rolled a try see
like all right let's get on it and so
now they're there belatedly coming to
the game so getting back to spider-man
for a second can we at least all agree
that whatever they do with this reboot
considering that the first one the Tobey
Maguire one was only about 10 years ago
12 years ago some like that and then we
just had two other ones killing at least
agree we don't need him get we don't
need the origin story again we don't
need believes we all know anyone that
doesn't know how do you had in
spider-man become a spider he was bitten
right by a spider radioactive spider
yeah so we don't need that why they skip
that part yeah I would love that but
comic books did that they had tons of
issues right so you can do more than
this just that one story but yeah I
don't know it did we've been introduced
and people who did need introduction
have avoided me on it to be fair the the
amazing spider-man which is the the the
Andrew Garfield ones they were operating
under a little different universe than
the Sam Raimi's spider-man trilogy was
which is not to say yes enough with the
[ __ ] spider bite we edit move on take
it as read look like can't they instead
just if you don't want to read the
freaking comic book and somehow you
missed it through all the movies can
they just hand you
she know but previously by spider let's
pre previously on Homeland give me like
30 seconds at the beginning and boom
with you know everything you need to
know do you guys think that I think the
most underrated series with all these is
x-men actually because not only I
thought that the three originals were
good and the two new ones that the Bryan
Singer ones I thought were good but that
all the way they all actually do linked
together which is pretty amazing
considering they've been in the future
they've been in the past they've been in
the president it all welcome that well
that's another one which like spider-man
is it the the Marvel there that didn't
sorry Marvel jettisoned or to another
state Gator right now before disney came
in to sort of say run the whole show and
and the fact that that that Fox has not
had to make a similar deal to sort of
incorporate them into the sort of
Avengers universe is that they're doing
fine on their own they're they you know
the the movie sort of vacillate in
quality I think there is a good with
some terrible ones but you're right
they've they've managed to create a
self-contained universe for themselves
so they don't need to go running back I
think the reason is that Sony is
reaching out the Disney here is because
they have lost their way and don't these
movies aren't working and so they want
to hitch their wagon onto something that
is worth does seem like it's the
storyline thing is that the x-men and
they don't have to reach out to others
maybe only because they continue to
create new stories with the same
characters the joy like which is ok we
want to see new stories yeah pay for
that so to that point so you were never
a comic book guy and you're a kid never
know so one of the things that I think
is interesting about this is I was into
comic books and I was a kid particularly
spider-man x-men a couple others you
think we're losing something even even
as someone that wasn't into the comic
book part you think we lose something
with all you know it's like we talked
about with all the technology of time
like kids just don't read them anymore
like I know comic books still exist but
it's not like it was back in the day
where Scylla to Norwich finding a people
our age 80 and older than me I've got a
couple kind of looks in my place but
even you lose something just the reading
aspect where your imagination and you
could actually turn a page and you
didn't have to just see it once and then
you know it disappears for two years it
must be a mid-range group of kids that
you know maybe they were still around
when they were books and now they're
around when there's also the electronic
book and it was doing this cuz I mean I
have a three-year-old kid and he knows
how to turn pages cuz we make him read
books you know or he actually has books
at home on his shelf yeah but there's
still
when there's something electronic in
front of them we were completely going
away from it at any point where I think
his generation when he's 16 like why
would I pick up a comic book I'm gonna
download it it's gonna pop in front of
my face yeah we're right like literally
like a holler and it is too but at least
are still reading it there you just not
on on you know dead trees as they say I
mean yeah look this stuff is always
going to be changing and and I think
that even I don't think it's that it's
not these movies fall the people are
reading comic books yeah people already
come with you people are reading period
or they aren't buying you know you look
at the sales figures from the sixties at
what x-men issues sold what even like
romance comics that were aimed at girls
sold like that was a market you know um
and now it's a different thing but I
think if anything the movies are
probably sort of made up propping up
what's left of the comic book industry
at least the mainstream superhero
industry all right mainstream superhero
industry you're going to be just fine
Alonzo second